bonsoir à vous mr fait d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir sur arte france
d'abord une réaction à cette
interpellation d'un jérôme rodriguez
cette figure du gilet jaune et gilet
jaune mais une interpellation qui je
l'espère n'est pas musclé comme il le
dit il faut voir un petit peu il y aura
certainement une enquête là il va leur
paraître en audition il était libre ce
soir apparemment et j'espère pour lui il
est en bonne santé
après les groupes d'extrême gauche ont
voulu faire cette contre manifestation
ici s'ils ont pris un peu tard d'une
réglementation dans ce pays il faut la
suivre mais on ne peut pas quand
j'entends dessus rodrigues aux nourrices
rodriguez pardon de dire a marre de
cette police on ne peut pas faire
l'amalgamme complète avec la police je
ne fais pas d'amalgamé justement il a
bien précisé dans le gros courant de 7
dans mon courant de cette interview sans
faire l'amalgamme avec l'ensemble des
forces de l'ordre la pluie
oui mais dans ses propos de fin indique
quand même qu'il faut changer avec cette
police qui maltraitent les gens en effet
ce sont des images qui ne sont qui sont
forcément un petit peu choquant il faut
derrière il y aura certainement une
enquête et puis on va l'audition de
monsieur rodriguez le rassemblement
national qui qu'ils plaident en faveur
des libertés on le voit dans le cadre de
cette crise sanitaire en ce qui concerne
notamment les restrictions
est-ce que vous trouvez normal tout de
même que cette contre-manifestation soit
interdite alors déjà une contre manif la
contre-manifestation nom des antilles
fort mais c'est vrai que moi j'appelle
les antifas aller voir un petit peu les
manières les méthodes qui était celle de
mussolini et de franco et on verrait ce
que c'est vraiment le fascisme
gilles génération identitaire ça défend
des idées qui ne sont pas celles des
gouvernements du gouvernement mais on a
le droit de ne pas avoir les mêmes idées
que le gouvernement alors ils veulent
faire une manifestation
mais en effet il fallait dans ce cas là
la déclarant préfecture dans les délais
mais lorsqu'on voit les images la
manifestation des générations
identitaire en est quand même loin des
débordements successifs que nous auquel
nous habitue tous et où tous les
manifestants d'extrême gauche des
personnes qui fit sa qui finissent à
l'hôpital où des personnes qui sont
arrêtés par la police mais on a souvent
entendu
rassemblement national soutenir aussi
des mobilisations interdite non
autorisées au sénat c'est souvent arrivé
donc dans ce cas là précisément qu'est
ce que vous dites mais le reste était
plaidé pour la liberté de tous de
pouvoir se mobiliser et manifester bien
sûr mais on est pour évidemment cette
liberté d'expression mobilisation ni
hatem cas un cadre juridique une
manifestation ça se déclare en
préfecture au préalable donc qu'il ya
derrière une contre manifestation qui
n'est pas eu qui n'est pas pu se faire
d'un en effet c'est dommage mais la
prochaine fois peut-être qu'ils
prendront leurs précautions pour pouvoir
la faire jusqu'au bout et et vous
soutenez la mobilisation de génération
identitaire qui fait mobilisés du côté
de denfert rochereau justement pour
dénoncer la volonté de gérald darmanin
de dissoudre l'association
le groupe a weak je soutiens
complètement on soutient complètement
parce qu'une association à la pâte pour
but de plaire ou de déplaire un
gouvernement ou un parti d'opposition
il ya des principes fondamentaux dans
notre république française la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'association et
la volonté de gérald darmanin de vouloir
dissoudre génération identitaire c'est
tout d'abord contraire aux principes
fondamentaux de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme alors ils sont très
attachés à l'europe mais il faudrait pas
y être attaché que pour les choses qui
les arrange
on a le droit d'avoir d'être une
association ils ont droit de penser
différemment ils n'ont jamais été
condamnés pour rien la dernière
manifestation qui s'est passé le 19
janvier au col du portillon dans les
pyrénées mais le préfet de des pyrénées
a reconnu que c'est une manifestation
pacifique
c'est plutôt une position une posture
donc oui on soutient complètement
quelle est la position du rassemblement
du rassemblement national
vis-à-vis de justement de génération
identitaire nous allons faire communiqué
de presse par rapport à ça on soutient
toutes les associations génération
identitaire on partage un certain nombre
de choses avec eux on n'est pas
forcément on n'est pas d'accord avec
tout ce qu'ils font tout ce qu'ils
disent ou toutes les actions qu'ils
mènent
néanmoins on soutient la volonté de
l'association
donc nous soutenons bien évidemment
génération identitaire la génération
identitaire qui a mené des opérations
très médiatisées contre les migrants
notamment dans les pyrénées qui tient
aussi des propos anti immigration votre
avis là dessus des c c'est à dire que
génération identitaires ne se mobiliser
contre les carences de l'état c'est
contre une immigration clandestine c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qui reprend le
symbole des frontières au niveau de la
france c'est pas pour tout ces
migrations contre l'immigration
clandestine lycée à l'etac et c'est
l'état qui devrait se positionner
là-dessus génération identitaire c'est
un lanceur d' alerte
en effet l'état ne joue pas son rôle et
puis ce qui est plus grave dans tout ça
c'est que la volonté de gérer les larmes
à 6 effet les opérations spectaculaires
que l'on a vu contre des migrants
c'est arrivé quand même plusieurs fois
spectaculaires madame excusez moi ils
sont un groupe quand même toujours
pacifique c'est un groupe restreint
c'est une question de posture et
mobilisation lorsqu'il se met sur une
frontière
oui c'est un oui en pompage je peux
comprendre au moins un lanceur dallaire
qui disent l'état ne fait pas son rôle
par rapport à l'immigration clandestine
faut quand même rappeler que ce sont des
gens qui rentrent sur notre sol mais qui
rend de manière illégale sur les réseaux
sociaux le groupe est très actif
il se définit comme une ligne de
résistance notamment face à
l'uniformisation des peuples des
cultures et pointe encore l'immigration
votre point de vue là dessus sur son ses
actions sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que je vous ai dit en préambule
nous ne soutenons pas ni toutes les
actions ni tous les propos qui est mal
de génération identitaire c'est pour ça
le génération identitaire n'est pas
l'antichambre du rassemblement national
ce sont vraiment deux entités
différentes c'est une association nous
sommes un parti politique
après contre l'immigration clandestine
oui c'est quelque chose que nous
soutiendrons toujours puisque ces
identités de la france et la dissolution
que souhaite gérald darmanin les
conséquences d'une telle décision selon
vous mais ça serait des conséquences qui
serait dramatique pour plusieurs choses
déjà comme je lui ai dit en préambule on
est contraire à la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
déjà c'est que c'est que c'est quand
même un manifeste qui est très important
deuxièmement si on ne peut pas dans ce
cas-là être contre l'immigration
clandestine et qu'on est taxé de
xénophobie ça voudra dire qu'en france
on pourra plus avoir de débat là dessus
et ça ça posera un réel problème de
démocratie après par la suite s'il
génération identitaire est dissoute
j'espère qu'ils iront y aura une
décision du conseil d'état et quels
seront leurs faveurs car là car ce
serait injuste
ils ont le droit de penser différemment
merci à vous hélène laporte merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france rappelle que vous êtes heureux
député et membre du rassemblement
national
merci